time will tell
it always does even when time is
[Music]
short
so a bit of news dropped about
the upcoming series 13 of doctor who
namely that it is going to be shorter
now in many ways this shouldn't be all
that
surprising i mean of all the stuff
that's been disrupted by kovid
toss my favorite tv show onto the pile
sure
why not but that is the uh the official
line
on that now the uh they're still calling
it the festive special that's still
coming out i believe
uh the best indication right now is that
that is end up gonna be
new years and that it's not moving back
to christmas which i think
if they could get it back to christmas i
think that would be better for the show
but once they got off that slot i don't
know if it's possible for them to get
back on it
anyways so that will happen and then
we'll get series 13
next year probably not until the autumn
so that honestly
i i think that'll be a wash i don't
think that'll hurt it
under other circumstances i might say it
would be a good thing but obviously with
everything so thrown off it's
it's weird what i mean by that is i do
i i have a suspicion that part of what
hurt series 12 in the ratings was the
fact that they moved it up to the front
of the year
which is where doctor who has never been
airing before and not that
shifting something around the schedule
is as disruptive as it was
you know in the back in the days when
you needed the freaking tv guide
but it doesn't help and moving it back
to autumn where it would
normally sit i think long term that's
where it should be regardless
that said i'm not expecting that move to
help it
this time around because well
because it'll have been really dang long
time since the last proper series
because
series 12 was back to the start of this
year we're gonna have a special and then
wait until the tail end of next year
before we get more actual episodes so
that's it's probably not going to see
boost but if they can keep it an autumn
and just leave it there
i think that'll be better for the health
of the show overall
uh it's still not as bad as uh under
moffat where we had
series nine then two christmas specials
before we got a new proper series
crying out loud but yeah let's come back
to the uh
but yeah let's come back to the number
of episodes thing
so i'm gonna read the exact words from
the man himself chris chibnall
now just because i mentioned his name
don't throw out a whole bunch of fire
chip no but that's not the topic of this
video
like seriously you can hate the guy all
you want
that's not the topic of this video you
spam my comments i will block you i'm
sorry i'm
i'm out of patience i really am
so what he said was in this strangest of
years the doctor who production team
have worked wonders to get the show back
into production
given the complexity of making doctor
who and with new and rigorous coveted
working protocols it's going to take us
a little longer to film each episode
meaning we expect to end up with a total
of
eight episodes rather than the usual 11.
now honestly all that tracked
because um they
do have more rigorous you know cleaning
and social distancing and all these
safety precautions
in order to reopen production
in the uk and those precautions make
everything
take longer and so for the amount of
time they've been allotted to shoot this
thing
they're not gonna get as many episodes
in
now if you're anything like me the
numbers that he said at first there was
something a little weird about them
because he said okay so we're gonna do
eight episodes instead of the usual
11. now that threw me off at first
because
series 12 and series 11 were 10 episodes
but they were 11 if you counted the
holiday specials as well
so what that would seem to indicate is
a siri it says he's ta he's saying eight
as opposed to 11 instead of saying eight
as opposed to ten that would indicate
that we're getting a
seven episode series and a special
or an eight episode series and no
special
so uh that's that's probably what we're
looking at right now and again
the explanation is valid
i mean nobody should be risking their
lives to shoot entertainment
that they shouldn't i love this show i
want it to come back
but you know nobody should be putting
their lives at risk
in order for me to do that that's you
know
that's just being a decent person
i think but it still
makes me nervous it makes me nervous
because we've already gotten shortened
seasons
so like i mentioned series 11 and series
12 were already 10 episodes
now during
eccleston tennant and smith
they got 13 episodes by the time capaldi
was done he got 12. that's
um not counting holiday specials
so to cut those down to 10 for series 11
series totals
we've already lost episodes and now
we're going to lose more
and the thing is i don't have a ton of
confidence that
once we're on the other side of kovid
whenever that is
that we're going to get those episodes
back
we might it depends on the exact nature
of
how it is we are losing them now to hear
chris chipnoll
say it it sounds like they're being
allotted the same amount of production
time as they do normally but because
everything takes longer they can't shoot
as many episodes
if that is the case then as long as they
don't cut their production time
any more than they already have they
should still be able to get his
get back up to 10 episodes
but
look let me put it this way
if the people at the bbc for whatever
reason
either preemptively already kind of
wanted to trim
the length of the series or
if it goes out and they say you know
what that was fine
you can work with that many right and
they just leave it at that i could see
that
i mean this is not really directly
connected but you know when i was laid
off
in july let me be let me be very honest
they were going to eliminate my job
eventually
anyways with everything that was going
on at the company i worked for
there that was going to happen no matter
what they just used the circumstances of
covid
to do it at the point that they did
rather than having to wait longer for
like a more proper full restructuring of
the company to then get rid of me
and i feel like there's a possibility
that that might be what's going on
that while the
i don't want to say using covet as a
cover because like i said
safety procedures and everything else
valid do that but
it it's possible it might be allowing
some people at the bbc to do something
they already wanted to do
i don't know that is absolute
speculation on my end but
just the fact that the show is gonna get
a short season
makes me nervous because i feel like
i've just been looking down the barrel
of getting a little less
and a little less of doctor who
over the last few years and with the
holiday special moving around the
the show doesn't feel like the fixture
it used to be and like i said this like
i'm not going to blame
chibnall for this because like under
moffitt we had
some weird stuff go on and tenant you
had the
the year the of the four sporadic
specials which i mean granted they did
well ratings wise but like that was a
that was a weird year so like there have
been periods where the show's gotten
weird
but i've just got this worry
like some on the back of the pit of my
stomach i'm like i
i really hope that
this time next year i'm not talking
about them cutting it down
to six episodes you know
i i don't know doctor who
seems gonna be shorter these days this
is the kind of video that normally would
have put up in the
break room of geeks subscribe if you
have not already
where uh my more unstructured free
flowing sort of thoughts usually go
but this felt like something that should
go
here because i don't
know if anyone actually relies on me for
doctor who news but
it seems to happen semi-often that
people like oh i didn't realize that
when i put stuff up so i figured this
should go on the larger platform
doctor who shorter season what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it like share subscribe
i have a patreon that is what pays my
bills
since having been laid off so uh help me
out there
in any amount it is greatly appreciated
and there are rewards including getting
early uh previews of most videos and
um you know the usual stuff the likes
the shares the subscribes i have merch
all those things but uh you also don't
have to
because end of the day you are the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye